some of the little one of the standing
like oh that sounds fun
do you receive it hopefully everything
depends okay today what's the point
hey listen I'm your biggest fan i watch
them yeah oh you did what's that one
oh you ever watched it okay I always
wanted to know who was the guy who
watched that you know okay so now I know
okay
so it's three two one and we go online
hello everyone how's everybody today
only as good as I am I'm doing good
today got my son and the other side as
always hey guys so one of my son's I got
three sons this is my with the last one
though the one I almost forget you know
to have at the last moment today I want
to cover a couple things first where we
left off yesterday
Ahn's was discussing here the issue of
turning theories into assumptions and
then you know now the guy comes up with
a theory based on that assumption he
comes up with a theory and another
fellow goes up there and uses that
theory as an assumption and so on I
think almost option chains ok the chain
of assumptions the assumptions basic
premise is I make an assumption and I
make a theory based on that assumption
someone else takes my theory all right
let's say magnetism to explain something
else that's his assumption and explains
his theory with my theory anyway and
then somewhere down the line
someone's Theory might be completely
wrong just based on the fact that I am
messed up my assumption and everyone's
got that chain from me yeah and
sometimes we lose track of where we got
these original assumptions right and
okay that's one issue I want to cover
the other one I want to cover a couple
issues that came up with both the monkey
and Tom you know they raised a couple
issues on what we were discussing and
then finally I want to address today
individual who contacted lately I've
been in just starting a discussion with
them his name is Ivor or Eve or cat I
don't know which is the correct
pronunciation I'll say Eve or sounds a
lot like Igor you know
anyways the I want to address some of
the issues because he raises some
interesting issues he says talks about
point he talks about instant and he
talks about energy and so I'd like to
address a little bit about that see if
any of those have anything to do with
physics right okay so let's go first
with let's go with your chain of
assumptions what's the deal there so so
you know all like I can relate to that
in this way okay let me tell you where I
relate today when I go back and I study
light and I study gravity and so on and
I find some things I said where did he
get this who was the starting point you
know where was the starting point for
this issue and you go back in time and
it turns out that this guy used the
other guy as a reference and you go back
to that reference you and this guy used
someone else's a reference and so I
can't relate to what ansa saying here
you know you know a lot of this started
again in the 17th century keep this in
mind something sensory was is known as
the Scientific Revolution you know
that's when science or rich allegedly
started right and why because they
started doing experiments and they
didn't not trust mr. Aristotle they said
you know whatever the Greeks did that
was all you know in their heads there
that was just discussion they never
tested anything they never put their
theories to the test they never
experimented with their theories okay
and specifically you know one of the
famous issues out there is Galileo's
alleged the rolling stones along
inclined planes and possibly throwing
stones from the Tower of Pisa
okay and the issue there he wanted to
test
Aristotle's assertion that heavier
objects fall to the to the ground faster
than lighter ones you know
it sounds logical you know if you wait
like an elephant an elephant should fall
to the ground faster than an ant and it
turns out that they fall at the same
time and that is spooky grounded the
same yeah what did I say they fall at
the same time okay I meant the same
thing we got my son there you know
anyway the point is that you can throw
an elephant in an ant they both hit the
ground at the same time or should at
least and the question is that sounds so
counterintuitive I thought this bigger
animal this bigger weight this bigger
mass should hit the ground faster and
you know allegedly Galileo either
through rolling balls on inclined planes
or throwing stones from Pisa there's
different persons here and he came up
with you know a counter-argument says
you know Aristotle is simply wrong you
know he never tested his theory and you
know throughout that those years in the
early 1600s throughout the 1600s you
know 17th century a lot of people you
Robert Boyle Newton's they all did
experiments in their own little dark
basements and they started overthrowing
a lot of the notions they picked up from
tradition and so that's when the
Scientific Revolution really kind of got
a start okay and so since then we had
something else which is not physics it's
mathematics we had all these
mathematicians saying okay now we're
going to do everything with equations
we're going to run an experiment we're
gonna measure we're gonna put into a
nice little neat equation we're gonna
call those equations laws and you know
now that you have a law you have to
respect the law whether you like it or
not because it's God's law okay and I'm
saying none of that has anything to do
with science let alone physics
mathematics is not the language of
physics
the man of science does not use
mathematics at all and you're saying
bill you're crazy you're out of your
mind yeah I know I'm out of my mind let
me tell you why I'm not why I'm out of
my mind I can't well let the
psychologists explain that one nerd I'll
explain why science has nothing to do
with math physics has nothing to do with
math and math has nothing to do with
physics we've done that many times well
I'm gonna more time hard to go more
specifically into the Assumption change
okay okay okay
let me just cover this and we'll go
right back to the Assumption chain let
me tell you why just very briefly
science rational explanations math can
only describe and we covered that in the
last couple weeks and so if math can
only describe and science is about
explaining and clearly math not only has
is not the language of physics or
science physics being a branch of
science but has it has nothing to do
with science in physics we have to
explain I always use my little magnet
here fixes we have to explain how these
magnets attract what what causes this
effect
I need no mathematics to explain to a
little boy you know how that happens
give me a little piece of paper so we
can do the yes we do it somewhere okay
here we have a little piece of paper we
did this dangerous experiment yesterday
it's a science goggles on yeah yeah yeah
this is a very dangerous experiment it's
been done many times but only in the
presence of rational scientists such as
you know relativists and quantum
mechanics and that's this here goes okay
watch it carefully okay did you see any
physical object hitting the paper why
did the paper move was it spirits was it
energy or more specifically do we need
math
do we need math to explain this know if
there might even help yeah I think it
hinders but that's that's the more to us
that's more to the point is math help at
all know exactly how much speed the the
paper moved or how much energy came out
of your mouth none of that helps me
understand what the actual mechanism
what the domino effect was there that
resulted in moving the paper because I
don't need any quantities or equations
to explain that to a ten-year-old I say
look there's this body of gas we call
air it's made out of molecules it's made
out of atoms you can say look it's it's
just uh it's just a bunch of particles
fine I don't care and that's what the
but I don't see any particles all I see
is you going and the paper movie from
interaction at a distance and you say
how did that happen that's magic because
I didn't see anything in between there
and all you have to do it say look you
can't see the air oh okay now I
understand it perfectly assuming we have
a bunch of particles suppose I mean we
have you know atoms molecules then we
can understand the mechanism and I
always give another example just in case
and that relates to gravity you see a
farmer in the distance and he's tugging
he's going like this right and on the
other side you see a donkey boom who's
taking his neck out being pulled how did
he do that I don't see anything in
between them he's too far to see the
rope I'll make it even better you get
closer and closer and closer and you
don't see absolutely anything the guy
keeps doing like this and pulling on the
donkey from afar he said how did you do
it you use magic did you use energy that
you use force did you choose mass you
got a fishing line and he says no I use
the rope what do you mean a rope I don't
see anything oh oh I see why you can't
see the rope it's it's ultra
violence got an ultra violet color to it
so it's beyond our visible range okay
what you understand is okay it's kids
stuff it was probably not a donkey with
Errol I just couldn't see it and I
thought it was magic but once he
explains it and look there is a rope
there you just can't see it then
everything falls in place and so so we
don't need any math we don't need any
mass we don't need any energy we don't
need any force we don't need any time to
explain how the farmer pulled on the
donkey we need a rope we need a physical
object of physical mediator and that's
what physics is about explaining how
these things happen how a magnet
attracts another what is the mechanism
that compels a spoon to fall to the
floor not to the ceiling that's physics
not all this mathematical nonsense that
we see out there getting back now to
your thing yeah just now you mentioned
time which okay everything same way a
perfect example of assumption chain okay
but before I get to that I just thought
these are assumptions chains are really
deep because they go all the way to the
dawn of human sentience
yeah thousand years ago when they
started looking at these things you know
we we know know how to gain the conch
everything and everything okay everyone
builds on past knowledge well Newton
said I stand on the shoulders of
Charlotte what is that this is really
important to know the and why do we even
read history and stuff yeah I like
history like this yeah he's got to read
history so he doesn't repeat the same
mistakes but you know I'm talking I'll
and
everything we know today we didn't just
come up with it out of nowhere we got it
from our previous generation the guy
from the previous generation they got
from the we memorize is learn by rote is
that but we take what they give us and
then we build upon it okay but we take
it out face yeah yeah but we don't
question it because we don't pass some
test otherwise
no no because we don't pass the test
it's not it's not specifically about
school then what is it if I got
everything that you know everything that
you know that stopped it yeah everything
you know you go to the high school at
school no no no in the works where do
you get your knowledge you get it at
school how do you use the utensils for
example okay hot that forget school does
that come loose the issue if you need to
have utensil but he said now she tells
you that that was cool but this but but
when we say school it's confusing
because now we're talking about actual
teachers and it changes the is your
mommy's just trying to say and
everything that we know we got from past
generations so you know in a sense
everything is an assumption chain of
theory of such a theory assumption where
you kind of build on what you were given
and it's hard to know it whether what
you were given was the correct I mean
this is also talking more about
philosophy how to live yeah what's the
best way to live that's also different
than what is okay thanks
yeah yeah that's that's that is what
exists yeah but in in a sense they're
both they both spend everything that you
assumed today when you want to
brainstorm for white as magnets is it
work right yeah you have a very narrow
pool of theories to work with you don't
you don't have a hundred theories no no
you're right about them because maybe
there's no more than ten because there
are from the pool of Assumption chains
that you were kind of raised with or
that you just saw in your day to day
things that you kind of Intuit you kind
of build this this pool of assumptions
and they're kind of implicit assumptions
going back to time where you were trying
to figure things out like the speed of
light or gravity and time kept coming up
and then only when you disregarded time
as a faulty assumption did it make sense
yeah because you look at physics but
that's why these assumption chains are
very important I'm got in the way it's
it's it's it's important to keep in
perspective that all our assumptions
aren't just falling from the sky
that when someone makes a pool of
assumptions to then build upon his
theory
there's there's a whole history behind
the assumptions people make
so when someone for example you have
this problem very often where they say
oh there doesn't have to be a mediator
between two objects yeah it just it just
it just happens for a creative yeah
there doesn't have to be a rope or a
feed or whatever it just happens to be
there passes so they have this pool of
assumptions that they just kind of take
for granted is that taking for granted
part that kind of irks me because that's
also where teaching goes south well yeah
when you try to teach me something
and there are implicit assumptions or
biases that you have that I don't have
it's very hard to teach it's art you
can't skip that you can't skip that step
you get recovered later you guys though
I gotta be on the same page you can't
you can't start teaching calculus if I
don't even know how to add kind of thing
yeah you gotta go in steps you gotta go
in steps so there are certain I mean
this is the biggest problem do you have
when you're running just trying to get
people to understand
forget confronting or anything just
trying to get someone to understand one
theory they have to you have to kind of
bombard them with so many assumptions
yeah that they don't already hold that
it's it takes years for them to finally
get that Oh moment like oh now I get why
bill uses object shape is this yeah
because it is comprehensive but it's
like this web that you can't just take
one definition out of context and take
it on right for it to make sense you
have to take the whole thing and for
that it's let me ask you something uh
come over here I want you to show your
face here I'm not talking to God just in
case you know we have my youngest son
here is he's the guy on the other side
okay just just so you know that I'm not
talking to the wind area and assumption
regarding its it's kind of scary you
know when you hear this voice
in the wilderness okay so I'm just
trying to show the importance of
assumptions
yeah of the origin of assumptions yeah
sometime you know and and that is true
you know sometimes you take some things
at face value and what what do we mean
by that you're taking face value means
that you accept it or you believed you
know because you're gonna use in your
theory you you believe the assumption of
the theory of someone else someone else
had an assumption he came up with a
theory you take the theory his
conclusions his results and you say well
I'm gonna accept him as as a fact and
I'm gonna use him as my starting point
that's gonna be now my foundation and
I'm gonna build upon it you know like
Newton said you know I stand on the
shoulders of giants and so now you build
upon it but it turns out we do this over
and over from generation to generation
and at some point you know there's a
generation out there us maybe you know
we're 400 years later from Newton and
some of the galileo and so all these
people and we said world all this come
from where did we get the wave I I
looked up the wave you know a long time
ago now and you know I said okay 19th
century this who was famous you know
everybody just believed in the wave
version of light and it turns out that
if you take it before the 19th century
before 1800s it was Newton who roared
the particle and by particle they meant
corpuscle little dot little ball tiny
ball that's what they meant by particle
that's important and so they they dealt
with a particle for 200 over 100 plus
years then 19th century that went into
the wave you know he had started really
early at the century with Thomas Young
and he did his slit experiment said this
can only be explained with waves and we
had a friend Nell Augustine friend now
he's a French guy and he came up and he
looked at polarization he looked at also
the slit experiment he explained it in
terms of waves it kept going with
Faraday and eventually with you know
people like
Maxwell and Hertz and so on and they all
said you know mite is some kind of wave
transverse wave to be more precise they
abandon Huygens Christian Huygens he was
a guy from Netherlands and also
contemporary of Newton and they
abandoned his notion of a wave which
where he explained water waves he says
you know you have a point source that
explodes and turns into all these little
vibrations and each one is a point
source of the secondary waves and so on
down the line and they said well you
know what light does not really work
that way it's more like a transverse
wave and that's what James Maxwell
described okay mathematically well that
lasted until the 19th century when we
had mr. Planck Max Planck he came up he
said you know when I do the black body
radiation experiment you know I have to
consider that light comes in discrete
packets in discrete packages and people
say how can that possibly be the light
is continuous well he said yeah I think
so because remember Max Planck did not
believe in his own theory he said you
know this is what I present these are
the this is the math behind it that
describes it but I don't accept the
physical interpretation that you know
light comes in discrete packages well
that's when you know by the time they
got to the Solvay conference v sovereign
conference in 1927 they finally said
look you guys believe in the way we
believe in the particle let's do
something let's reach a consensus let's
shake hands and we'll make it a wave
particle particle wave wave packet
whatever you want to call it will merge
them both together and you know mr.
Niels Bohr says I'll come with a
complimentary principle which means that
for these experiments you can use the
wave and for these others you can use
the particle whatever you can't explain
what particles just use the way whenever
you can't explain it with waves use the
particle and so on
that's like that's like you
a soccer game we have two referees one
referee for your team on her 40 for my
team
yeah you can't explain so you reach a
consensus well science doesn't work by
consensus unfortunately science doesn't
work by consent I mean I don't care
about science as mother nature sure does
I hope mother nature doesn't say well
you know I think I'm gonna convert the
particle into her the corpuscle into a
way just explain the slit experiment
then I gotta convert it back to a
particle to explain just the masses
Compton's experiment and I gotta change
it back to a way to explain you know I
don't know the the or to a particle to
explain the photoelectric effect and
then back to the wave to explain
polarization mother nature you drive her
nuts if you if if she could convert you
know particles into ways and then when
you look at the particle it's not the
corpuscle that Newton talked about
corpuscle is a particle is really a one
no it's a field yeah it's a field and
what is a field you look at the word
field and it's an undefined were
dissolved words in mathematics they're
all undefined and when they relate to
you know when they try to give physical
interpretation so and the most important
word that's undefined is the word field
it's just you can think of it as a
spider's web that extends throughout the
universe that's the field yeah but think
of it in three dimension I'm not like a
flat you know two-dimensional spider's
web but think of it in three dimensional
radially and in a spider's the three
dimensional spider's web goes to the
edge of space time I guess I don't know
so it's a bunch of values that's around
an object that's all it is whether
you're talking about gravity you're
talking about the field for an electron
whether you're talking about the field
of a pion of a muon it doesn't matter
it's a it's a radially radial region of
values of magnitudes of units that's
what it's a mathematical concept so you
say hold it you're saying that this
field went through the slit how did he
get all these you know these spiderweb
web the Attar went through the little
split and so what is what particle start
yes it doesn't end in a rational
physical interpretation they convert the
part to go into a field they say that's
what went through the slit you say that
doesn't make any sense of course it
doesn't we don't understand quantum
mechanics that's that's the answer they
give you well that's what we ended up
with with the faulty assumption chains
so what we're kind of saying is kind of
the question everything all confronting
your assumptions I mean a good point to
make is that what we believe are
basically assumptions that we take for
granted
yeah it's any implicit assumptions that
you're make we're gonna call those
beliefs at least I'm gonna call that
belief belief to me the definition of
belief is an assumption that you take
for granted that you don't know sumption
is what you take for granted life means
that you actually turn it into a fact
belief means now you're not you're
saying when you give a presentation yeah
okay all the assumptions that you make
without stating them as such oh yeah but
it's really a belief oh yeah if someone
gives a presentation beyond they explain
my magnetism why these two magnets
attract each other yeah he's doing it on
earth he did that he's trying to explain
an observation that he did on earth
right here it is right there there's
gravity on earth yeah it has nothing to
do with the explanation but it might so
I'm in it so he's not invoking gravity
per se to explain it but he's but he is
implicitly there is gravity in the in
the gravity could have something to do
with it let's put it that okay good yeah
so so so so it's in the gravitational
field we're trying to explain magnetism
I mean as far as common sense goes
gravity has nothing to do with it but
all I'm trying to say is the he he's
implicitly invoking gravity so gravity
is more like a belief it's like we don't
have to talk about that everything that
he doesn't explicitly state okay we're
gonna assume I have
two pieces of metal we're gonna assume
they pull each other you just do all the
assumptions but there's a shitload of
assumptions that you make that you don't
state out loud like the column that
maybe not gravity but you might make
some other assumptions yeah kind of like
it's kind of in the realm of beliefs
where it's like till you take for
granted some things like oh you you know
right yeah yeah oh oh that's a belief
you have that I don't so you have to
explicitly state that until someone
challenges those challenges and now you
have to explain you what do you mean you
didn't go to high school you didn't go
to college
no I did please explain no I haven't
please explain if two mathematical
physicists would explain or one word to
explain something to the other there
they both had the same background or
there's a list of things that of
assumptions that they wouldn't have to
explicitly state because we both got
that physics 101 102 201 and all that
it's like there's a lot of things that
they can do shorthand with yeah and
those are more like beliefs like okay
we're both on the same page on that
let's try to build upon that a very case
in point time dilation they say what do
you mean time value we can't dilate time
time is not a physical object well you
don't understand the term titled
annihilation that means something else
and it's code you know within the
mathematical community there's a time
dilation that's a shorthand for a whole
bunch of other stuff that has nothing to
do with bending time you know what do
you do you've been the second you've
been the minute you've been a year what
is it that you bend over there at the
mathematical Club and they said well you
don't understand you haven't taken
mathematics what 202 or 101 or 302 or
whatever you haven't taken advanced
mathematics that's why you don't
understand because time dilation not
something else you're not on the same
page right and so the issue is they use
all these code words these code phrases
we transfer energy we move the mass this
problem like that carry the force and I
understand then you say well hold it
what do you mean you carry the force you
move the matter
great energy the problem with that is
the implicit assumption problem where
since they both believe they don't have
to explain that to each other they don't
visit the topic so it stays underground
it sees all the problems with with it
yeah well the youngest boy area yeah all
the hidden you know problems with within
a something kind of go unpunished yeah
because they both kind of go you know
what I mean we don't know we agree and
let's know I mean it's not we Twingo
touch because it's kind of like okay we
both took that class we don't have to
talk about it let's just build upon it
you know we don't really understand it
you're some third person came in some
layman and asked anyways what do you
what are you asking all the
quote/unquote dumb questions and then
they start going they start rolling
their eyes oh man you just have to roll
over these questions don't look at the
details yeah okay the literal yep I'll
take them literally you're not supposed
to take a mistake they want the implicit
assumptions that hurt to stay implicit
yeah they don't want to make those
explicit because now you got actually
look at them so so where do we conclude
as far as assumptions now about that an
interesting conclusion or a question
more they don't ask is because the moral
that we're kind of going around is to
question your assumptions to question
your beliefs question for example more
than your Larry's just just question
like just whatever you're thinking about
time question okay what is time you know
yeah and especially let me let me
clarify especially when you don't
understand I mean you don't just nod you
say excuse me you know could you clarify
that or John I'm too stupid to
understand this or am I talking more to
my to myself if I'm just in a room by
myself I'm trying to figure something
out yeah
then I you're kind of forced to look at
the implicit assumptions because there's
some assumption that you have that's not
making this it doesn't it isn't right
because you don't understand sumption so
start directly exactly so the pieces
don't fit so some pieces off which one
is it then you go one by one but then
the question becomes which is a very
deep question and you can't
underestimate it because it's one of the
fundamental questions which is
where do you draw the line on what to
question yeah yeah and example you don't
you don't question that there has to be
a mediator between two objects to
explain action at a distance I know but
a lot of people do and it blows my mind
when people say why do you need a
mediator and I'm saying you mean this
particle effects this one at a distance
gravitationally electromagnetically any
way you want and you've seen this one
effects this one at a distance they call
it entanglement in quantum and there's
no physical mediator what do we do with
them with spirits I mean what are we
gonna introduce in that space
think about that test but then the
question the you didn't answer yet or or
this for anyone listening is learning
where do you draw the line on with the
question because you do questions some
things well I think some things are more
than common sense I would put them above
common sensical it's like I I don't have
a word to describe it it's like you're
born with it
it's like no one had to teach me in my
entire life I didn't have to go to
school for this yeah I was born with it
I can say that between two point of this
particle I've touched that when if the
farmer pulls on the donkey if the magnet
pulls on the magnet there's some
physical mediator in there it's like you
know for me it's it's it's a non-issue
and our people who say what do you need
a mediator or what do you need to put an
object in there now then and it just
blows my mind so what are you doing
physics with how do you think a magnet
pulls on another with magic with spirits
or will God what do you put in we do
magnets nothing nothing we're just gonna
keep it humid unanswered I mean you know
here we have this guy pulls on that one
I can't even break all apart yeah is
that you and then it sticks and it
doesn't from it I can already feel it
pulling here you know and you know here
I'm trying to put them together and I
can't
let's go see that's what I'm saying
hold it there if there's nothing in
between there but that's what is it
spirits God angels what are we gonna put
in their energy mass what do you want to
put in there that's why it works is
that's why the questioner run is where
do you draw the line on what to question
because well do questions some things
but there is like there are some beliefs
or assumptions that you kind of say okay
I'm not going to touch these yeah but
you know what I did what I do is divide
people into scientists rational people
and irrational religious people and I'm
saying it's a religious person who
believes that two magnets are attracted
to each other or repulse each other
without without a physical mediator
these people simply weren't born with
common sense yes that's just that one
for example time at some point you were
actually debating in your head so you
you had the time assumption yeah so you
say you were brainwashed to talk about
time so I said okay all these equations
have mass they have time and that's what
I looked at you know I looked at the
equations and I said okay here's time
here's mass and that was just a
stumbling block but at the moment I
didn't realize that I said okay this guy
did this with time you know like take
just Newtons simple force equals mass
times acceleration you look at
acceleration
it's got time in there you know meters
per second squared and you say ya thank
ya you got second you got time you GE so
it was like I took of a grand I said
okay you got time into you you need to
include time and it turns out that
that's a description of what's happening
obviously you can't say that the car ran
because some time had something to do
with it
time was not a factor in pushing the car
forward if I have to explain the
mechanism the cause I don't need time at
all thank it's weird
yeah it doesn't weird no no obviously
not but what I'm saying is that's when
you start saying why I don't need time I
don't need mass is that I don't need
energy I don't need any of those words
invented by mathematical physics what I
need to know is what physic
objects are involved in pushing that car
forward you know if someone tells you
look I'm technician mechanic you go to
take your car to the mechanic and say
how does a car work do you think this
mechanic you gotta say well let me talk
to you about energy and force and mass
and time no look the gas comes out of
here goes to the student comes to the
engine he's gonna talk about objects
he's got to talk about physical entities
and again you know how did that happen
did it happen through energy mass what
was it no it was air that I blew against
in other words all the all the things
involved are are objects and I can make
up a movie of my theory I just have to
make the air visible that's all
once I make it visit with us it's for
kindergartners you blew something
invisible which are all these particles
you blew against the paper and paper
whew very simple it's like the wind
blows the trees down you know or the
cows down hurricane you know we all
understand that we don't need any math
any fancy words concepts less such as
energy force and mass to explain that so
going to the title of the video uh-huh
about points the word point used in
science let me give you what I mean I
get this feeling that you got to talk
about the faulty assumption that they're
making yeah here we're dealing with
assumptions we have this individual of
his name is Ivor Kat I believe I'm
pronouncing his name correctly no no he
came through a friend of mine and and I
we started just discussing just couple
days ago so you know I don't know him
well you know I don't know all the
things he's got coming I just presented
my my version of physique I said look
the golden principle of physics is
physics requires an object you can't do
physics without an object yes or no and
then I'll take that which has shape yes
or no he didn't answer that question but
he had an early
answer to these questions where he says
the following he says where is it here
he starts out with us he says I start
with primitives or a primitive what is a
primitive it's an undefined word that's
what it is that's what primitive means
means you can't define it in more fount
fundamental words because those words
indeed require definitions as well and
so on down the line forever so they call
those primitives and what they do what
the mathematicians do is simply get
around from defining the p-word they
have to define I need I need a
definition for the word point and
they'll never define it to clarify that
for example the word motion its effort
would be a an example of a primitive
energy what they're essentially saying
is there are certain words that you
can't define because it would destroy
their theories that's the way I look at
it like they can't define the word
motion or location because why not it
requires other words to define them and
then you go off on a tangent of science
or something like that yeah we're gonna
get the notion that they're going
forward but it's still not I would call
what they're doing is avoiding a
definition that's what they're doing
they're avoiding because they don't want
to do grammar they want to do math they
want to do equations then I'm saying any
questions have nothing to do with
physics yeah because you can't bring
equations into you which we need to
explain how a magnet attracts another I
need no math to do this and the issue
with primitives is I think there's that
just shows the level of kind of what do
you call it
avoidance they it is it's a void is not
even avoidance it's it's under
estimating that's what I'd say hundreds
to me who they don't they don't they
underestimate words and definitions
yeah they don't it's not held on us at a
pedestal as it should be in science yeah
it's underestimate it's not it's kind of
like we're gonna do we're gonna operate
on a human body but we're not gonna use
something that's Ivy is or something and
let me tell you why let me tell you why
it's developed that way the way it
developed is that from the days of
Newton what they've done is they
believed at all
that math is the language of physics and
science requires math that's that's
where it all starts and so they always
were looking for these laws of God I
guess you could call them laws of the
universe where they say look we can we
can explain everything with equations
but it turns out that math cannot
explain and you know we had the
statements let's see if I can find it
here do I still have it I don't know if
I have it um is it maybe no well okay I
lost it somewhere but we had yesterday
and the day before we had Nobel Prize
winner Stephen Weinberg we had a
professor Donald Simic from Pennsylvania
University Lock Haven University
he's a emeritus professor they both said
the same thing science doesn't explain
science describes why because math
describes so the equated science meaning
physics with math and so they say you
know you need math for physics that's
why because that's what they do they do
equations
you don't need math for physics I need
to explain how a magnet attracts another
I need to explain why a pen falls to the
floor and not to the ceiling that's what
I need to explain what was the argue
where did the argument start with this I
wore well more of us here yeah you know
essentially not signing it to the bottom
oh I'm trying to get to the foundations
of physics what is physics about that's
essentially what I'm talking about what
is because we don't seem to agree or be
on the same page as far as what physics
is concerned so he gives me an idea here
he says I start with primitives right
okay and by that he means primitive
means undefined words so he starts with
undefined words that's what primitive
means means that he can't define his own
terminology okay fine so we go to the
next step and says at a point
okay he's gonna bring Euclid's point
here that's essentially what he's
talking about there is no knowledge
about the rest of the viewers at that
instant well instead or a point his
point an instant incident is a point
point is location location is point
point is a number number is a point what
are we talking about when we say point
well obviously it's a primitive word
because they don't want to define it if
you define it as a dot which is what
they put on the board objectively that's
what a point is a dot and you say what
are you gonna do with that dot it's a
two dimensional dot and they say no it's
a zero dimensional what do you mean
server that match I see two dimensions I
thought all dots have two dimensions a
minimum maybe they have three but for
sure they have two and they say no no
you're mistaken see it's how we locate
the point and we need we need zero
dimensions to locate a point because
it's where it's at okay need two
coordinates entered the crab a plane one
coordinate to describe a line and so on
it has nothing to do with physics none
of that has a lot of geometry garbage
invented by Euclid has nothing to do
with physics what was he trying to
explain well I don't know well let's get
to the following says there is no
knowledge about the rest of the errors
at that instance so a point is an
instant which is where who knows what
else it's an undefined word there might
recite something something whatever
something is because that's the word I'm
trying to get to the other word
something at that point there is
something at that point now he treats it
as a location that is an instant and
there may be something arriving at that
point at that instant so what is he
saying yeah I know we're having
something which is the word we're trying
to get to and he doesn't pay attention
to this he said well we don't care about
what something is we're just saying
something arrives at that point he's
worried about location he's worried
about instant he's worried about for
sure numbers but he's not worried about
what the object looks like is it an
elephant is it an ant he said we don't
care wait why don't you care don't you
care in physics whether it's an elephant
or an ant he said no because we're gonna
treat it mathematically we're gonna say
that something whatever that something
is arrived at that point
at a given point in time instant and
that's all we care of it we care about
the action not about the actor okay and
he continues I'm familiar with exh
energy current current traveling at sea
velocity alight right some of which may
pass through that point through the
point yeah so he's got energy passing
through that point but he says it has
energy density not energy so you know
his energy density not see it when you
read these things there are so many
things that I mean granted yes but it's
it's he's not explaining anything
because he's using words that he
understood let's let's listen let's give
him different
yeah let's give him the benefit of the
doubt and say okay he understands the is
ranked vertically and it makes sense to
him to him and it's exactly how mother
nature does it right those guys called
the full mile but that doesn't go there
are you something ah I turn something
off no I'm good
you're good I don't think so give it
heaven fire fire you're fine
I don't know what I may be nervous fuss
I'm nervous now but I don't I don't know
why I can't see myself okay Frank so so
so we're gonna we're gonna grant him the
benefit of the doubt okay you know what
he's talking about and it's exactly how
a mother nature runs our shop that's
exactly how the universe works we're
gonna use their with energy density and
energy whatever that means
yeah but that's the problem if he wants
to explain that to me yeah how does he I
don't know what he's saying
he said you got to go to college sue me
it's the gospel truth and it is like he
just happened to stumble on the the way
the universe works and it makes sense in
his mind I
it doesn't help anyone if he uses vague
terminology that I can't then adopt but
then he says that you got to go to
college to get a master's degree in
mathematics or whatever he studied in
order to understand his language but
then what's the point of even opening
his mouth no but this I will just hold
it
what we said yes sir this goes back to
what we said yesterday it goes to this
there are different levels okay so we
have the kindergarten level we have the
high school we have the elementary
school we have the college playing it up
to the college level here but you're
you're still in kindergarten so you
don't understand all my terminology and
so I say okay fine let's let's assume we
don't understand it's terminal let's
start from scratch
start with kindergarten I mean what did
Einstein say if you can't explain to a
barmaid you don't understand it well now
what did Fineman say make it value 70 he
says if you can't explain it to a
ten-year-old then you don't know it well
enough also something that's my point
she uses energy density right okay not
not to be a dick or anything I'm not
saying hey define your words or else you
lose not even with that tone let's just
break it down for me I'm stupid
break it down for me I want to
understand what you're saying I want to
have in my head will you have in yours
yeah and you can't do that with vague
terminology if you ask me to explain how
the refrigerator works and I say the
blorgon move the door board now you have
to break it down then we don't
understand you know what you're talking
about
no no but again I always say the
following and I think this is the best
way to put it
mathematics is for PhDs physics is for
kids yeah if you cannot explain and I
think Einstein and Fineman said it
properly there if you cannot explain it
to a ten-year-old then you have no idea
what you're talking about
okay you're not doing physics you might
be doing math you can talk about
Einstein's is a field equations you can
talk about you know Niels Bohr and all
his all his equations and Heisenberg and
Schrodinger and whatever you have no
idea what physics is about if you want
to talk to a to a kid you got to talk
physics you got to say look this is how
this is how the farmer pulls on on a
donkey you pull with a rope and
everybody will understand and I can make
a movie of that and
and if I start saying look you need to
understand what energy is you need to
understand what mass is and then you
take mass and you push that with so many
and this here's the equation for it etc
you lost the guy the guy can't follow
you saying well you have to think of
course in in physics at the a university
level and then and then after all that
they still insist and they say they give
you the fine print or the closing
arguments a nobody understands quantum
mechanics no kiddin if they don't
understand them certainly I'm not gonna
understand mother nature's not gonna
understand it you can't explain quantum
mechanics to mother nature period I
think we're done I think this is the
issue that we're kind of going around
what is it are the three kind of forms
of communication of math words and
movies where math and words really just
kind of convolute me giving you
information if I just show you the movie
of what I mean right
it's it's this goes to I got interrupt
you there because Tom Haggard yesterday
sent it properly he said the following I
got a reader over here because I can't
see I don't know why I can't see my
image there in the OBS he says the Fonz
wait for can I come out for it to come
out it's rational if you can visualize
the mechanism logic doesn't need to be
visualizable
so he says there's a 73 yeah you said
that yesterday at the end he says
there's a difference between rational
and logic okay he says rational is what
you can visualize I make a movie of my
physics theory I visualize it there on
the screen
and I don't need to use a single word I
show you how a car works by showing you
the whole movie in a silent movie will
bring Charlie Chaplin to before us okay
logic does not need to be visualizable
logic you say if a then B that's right I
said yesterday yeah yeah and you can do
it with computers computer doesn't have
to visualize anything but a rational
he's distinguishing rational from logic
yes that was the issue one more word
okay
there's a difference between imaginable
and rational but this how I would define
it imaginable is just any shape that you
can have in your head okay rational is
making taking something in real life and
then making everything that's invisible
visible
when you want to explain something you
can't I mean yeah you can visualize an
angel but when you use the superpowers
now how are you gonna rationally visual
visualize it you can't do that and
that's and that's one of the issues that
you know I was also going to present an
example you can present a theory
involving angels you can say look here's
an angel and you showing this human with
wings and a little cup on his head or
you know a little ring or whatever on
his head okay plate or ring and and so
now you say look here's my theory that
my theory is that angels move the earth
around the Sun now they can make a movie
of that I can make a movie of angels
moving around the Sun and you say okay I
understand your theory is imaginable
it's imaginable because I can put it on
the screen but now let's look at the
assumptions okay we're gonna go now for
you go back to assumptions and we say
okay hold it I got a couple problems
what does an angel have wings I mean
wings on earth you know birds are
because they use them for air and out
there in space there's no air so what do
they have wings that's one issue another
one hold it these guys have superpowers
like you know they have so much they
have little mass because you're the
little angel he's just a human maybe
he's a little bigger I don't know and
and he can push the earth around well
where does he get the mass to push the
earth around the Sun and so you have
questions about the Assumption not about
the theory the theory you can understand
you can say okay I see what you're
saying you're saying the angel pushes
the earth around the Sun we can all
understand the mechanism we can't
understand the Assumption the
superpowers why he has wings maybe some
other reason why more to that point
specific by his place floating and
around his head but something why can't
we understand it is because to
understand something there's a key
invisible thing the
to make visible right some invisible
mechanism there's something that you
didn't know you didn't see make it
visible exactly if you have the car hood
closed you're not gonna understand
anything you got to open up shut up show
me exactly every single business going
on there how they guess I just do the
magician is also good when he does why
does why does the magician have the box
at all yeah I mean it happened because
of magic is is why not show you if it is
to hide a part of it so so that you go
holy crap how do you do it is that what
Mother Nature does is called Penn &
Teller with did they do this there's one
trick with a box where it's two
magicians okay kind of pops out of this
side he pops out of that size feeder
over here how's he doing this and then
after they do the trick they do the
whole thing where he was pregnant yeah
they do the whole thing with the open
box last box we can see exactly where
he's going or where he's putting his
feet or he's putting his hands now so
that's the point of science yeah but
look look here we have two magnets I
imagine nature's fooling us you say look
I can do magic I can make these things
come together from afar here go the
pools already okay and it's holding it
right and you say well how did you do
that Mother Nature well I'm not gonna
show you the the visible parts the
invisible but I'm not gonna make them
visible to you I'm gonna let you break
your brain to see figure out how I did
this man that's right the whole point of
explaining is making something invisible
visible if I say if a really loud sound
happens right yeah in the kitchen you
know what was that and I say oh I saw it
was the plate it fell on the ground then
you kind of go okay in your head you can
now visualize the thing that way family
now right now you say that was a spirit
yeah if you hit her gee yeah you can't
you can't just say I mean you have to
put some object in the effect of
something hoping that hopefully that's
what I'm saying you got a make there's
there's a nice thing between two magnets
and you got to make that object visible
if you want to understand the theory
yeah if you put nothing there for sure
no one
understand the theory and if you put a
concept there such as energy mass force
whatever you want to put in there that's
a concept information love
no one's gonna understand your theory
you have for sure you have to there's
something invisible they have to make
visible yes you gotta be lying and you
can't make any months of visit but that
goes back to you can't make a concept
visible yeah you can be any concept
visible but it kind of goes back to what
I was talking about with movies words
and math where maybe at physics
conferences everybody should just and
there should be an unspoken rule of note
of complete silence no one can talk more
yeah show us the movie and long line
experts next presenter movie I got it I
got your idea that's a good idea
we're we're gonna we're not gonna accept
blind people but we're gonna accept
death I just want to look at your movie
anytime there's an effect yeah what are
you gonna put in each friend you got to
put an object that's my point
any time what do you put any reason you
want to explain the phenomenon yeah an
effect any affair you hear something you
see something you feel something there's
something and you and you okay let's
think I'll see because that's all that's
the whole point
yeah if you feel something hear
something taste something or smell
something but don't see it now there's
something to explain yeah that's the
whole thing explain these literally that
visualize the visualization where you
magic what doing it with magic what can
I imagine in my head what's the thing
that I put in my head to explain that
effect if something pushes something and
I'll see it okay what how do we explain
this if I smell something now where's
that smell coming from you don't see it
obviously you're just looking for
something invisible to make visible to
explain I like to use the Kern there you
know the curtain moves and your friend
says well you know the the reason the
curtain moved is my great-grandmother's
spirit is in the room and she moved the
curtain and you say well
if you close the window anything because
maybe there's a different explanation
extrapolate anything - you don't see for
example if you have a pain in your
stomach you feel something you have an
effect and you can't see it and you
can't see it so what you're trying to do
when you try to explain it is you're
trying to make okay what's the visible
thing I obviously can't see it but
you're trying to imagine it right you
try to on your stomach and you just see
it with your brain if I put a rock like
in my head if I if in my imagination I
put a rock in my stomach right
what do you explain this sensation right
so you put a rock you see you simulate
it with a rock yes a is this causing to
pain then you say no let's try a
bacterial theory today your brother and
or whatever caused the pain is
essentially trying to make you you're
never gonna see it you're simulating
whatever ideas come to your mind you're
trying to explain what's causing the
pain and explaining is literally making
something invisible visible and not even
like literally just in your head just
having something to imagine if you can
imagine it you understand it and with
that we will see you tomorrow at the
same time same station and tomorrow our
class is just gonna be movies tomorrow
we're not gonna talk at all tomorrow
we're just going I think we're gonna put
Charlie Chaplin silent movies and
whatever we find before 1927 when they
invented you know someone said this to
me when we were talking about magnets
the concept shape comes from visual and
this visual a visual and tactile
perception the inherently unseeable and
untouchable need not have shape the
inheritor unseeable no no art it's not
an issue of whether we see or now we we
remove the we kill all the observers in
physics there are no observe in
mathematics there are observers in
physics we have no observers so we don't
have to see we don't have to touch we
have to imagine we see with our brain
you in object by definition is that
which has shape so so whether I can see
it or not I can't see the air you know
here it is
I can't see the air but hopefully
there's a physical object there I'm not
doing this with magic believe me okay
please believe me thing is untouchable
yeah they were in the 1950s The
Untouchables somebody on the physics
yeah I mean seriously there's no such
thing as an untouchable thing well it
has it has no effect
untouchable is a touchy word tomorrow
yeah we don't know just off the top of
my head there's no such thing is
untouchable if it's untouchable it
doesn't exist kind of thing it's
untouchable that means it has no effect
yeah the problem with the touchable is
that you have to run an experiment to
find out if it is touch like the star on
the other side of the universe I can't
see it I can't taste it I can smell it I
can't do anything with it
is it touchable well let me run the
experiment I'll tell you yeah yeah you
need an experiment certain thing I'm
just talking about logically you know
there's something that's untouchable
right assuming assuming we we knew for a
fact whatever we did the experiment
everything if it's untouchable what's
the point even talking about yeah but
hold it hold it hold it
it's a big word because now we have to
define what you mean by touch and we'll
get to that tomorrow especially for the
rope model of light and the atom you
need to know what touch against because
it has to do with the issue of tangling
you know people ask well don't these
ropes tangle when they cross each other
and before they tangle they must touch
right because you know it's like you
just visualize it for a second two ropes
coming together right first they touch
then they can go through each other or
do whatever they want but first they
must touch so we have to explain touch
before me to explain
tangley and we'll do that tomorrow we'll
see you then tomorrow same time same
station bye bye